donald trump lo avisó el mismo día de la
elección de ganar es fácil perder nunca
lo es no para mí durante su campaña el
presidente egipto los fantasmas de un
presunto fraude en el voto por correo
una modalidad cuyo uso creció a raíz de
la pandemia y que históricamente es más
utilizada por los demócratas
tienen millones de boletas no
solicitadas enviadas a todas partes eso
no es bueno es tremendo
meterse en la noche de la elección con
ventaja en algunos estados clave pero en
un panorama aún incierto trump se
declaró ganador y repitió sus denuncias
sin pruebas
ganamos esta elección
nuestro objetivo ahora es garantizar su
integridad por el bien de este país este
es un momento muy importante es un gran
fraude en nuestra nación desde entonces
y frente al cambio son una tendencia
desfavorable trump y su equipo de
campaña han presentado denuncias para
detener el escrutinio en pensilvania
michigan georgia nevada y wisconsin sus
asesores legales en nevada e incluso han
asegurado que encontraron en la basura
una papeleta dentro de otra ambas
marcadas a favor del demócrata joe biden
sin mostrarlas y el mandatario alejado
del escenario público siguió su lucha en
twitter con consignas como frenan el
conteo y paren el fraude una guerra
dialéctica y judicial que podría llegar
en última instancia y tras superar los
tribunales locales a una demanda ante la
corte suprema- un escenario inédito
desde el año 2000 cuando el republicano
george bush se impuso al demócrata al
gordo
por wifi